was a picture
of me posing with a dead isis fighter
along with 12 other people and they came
back and had said that i had stabbed an
isis prisoner to death
and they had it on video is it common at
the end to take pictures of the enemy
you take out ncis does not like uh they
don't like navy seals they're always
looking to take someone take one down
and that's when the president stepped in
and said okay let him out of prison so
he can properly defend himself they
would send out women and kids in droves
running towards us and then mow them
down in front of us how do you train
emotional you know being seals and we
have a job to do we we're very mission
focused and after seeing what they do to
other humans you don't look at them as
human anymore
[Music]
so my guest today is chief eddie
gallagher he's a decorated veteran navy
seal eight combat deployments two bronze
stars with v for valor navy achievement
with valor
and uh depending on how you've seen his
story being told by which media platform
you either don't think uh highly of some
of the things that took place and maybe
some of the things he's not proud of and
maybe he'll talk about it with his new
book that just came out
or you look at him as somebody that
uh to understand what
he had to do to go against enemy that
are trying to do whatever they can to
dethrone america or take our freedoms
away to be able to do that job is not
everybody's job so we're going to take a
deep dive today on that story with that
being said eddie thank you so much for
being a guest on uh valuetainment today
yeah man thank you for having me on i
appreciate it first of all appreciate
your service you know you i was in for a
couple years
but you took it to a whole different
level
uh you know everybody every kid that
goes into the military we
admire we respect for someone you know
one day being an army ranger or you know
18 delta special forces navy seal you
were able to do that and you went out
there and faced off with some of the
most uh
feared opposition and enemies so i'm
looking forward to getting into that so
hey if you don't mind before we go into
some of the stuff with your book and
some of the controversy
around what took place with you
uh uh uh while you were in some stories
we'll cover that as well can you walk me
through your background let's go all the
way to high school if i was in high
school with you in 10th grade who was
eddie and what's the story with how you
got into the military
uh yeah sure so you know my dad was uh
in the army he uh graduated from west
point so he was in for about 24 years so
i grew up in army brat uh moving around
every two years mostly in asia
i spent most of my childhood but then
ended up in fort wayne indiana for high
school
after my dad had retired
um you know i was uh
i was a rambunctious kid just you know
school wasn't uh my thing i was just
always
getting in trouble in the mix but i i've
always had loyal friends everywhere i
went
um
and by the time i finished high school
you know which i barely graduated uh i
tried college
i gave that about half a semester and
realized i wasn't mature enough yet to
for college um so i decided to join the
navy uh it was
just a uh
decision i made to
get out of fort wayne indiana and uh try
and make something of myself and then
you know i went to the recruiting office
they uh you know the recruiter was going
over what jobs to have and i already
knew in my mind i wanted to be a
commando of some sort so i chose uh you
know i want to be a seal um
unfortunately back then there wasn't
like a straight pipeline to go to bud so
i went to boot camp i had to go to an a
school which i went to core school which
is a medic for the navy and then from
there i was assigned to the marines for
four years
and so i did my tour there with the
marines which was a
blessing you know i got to go to a lot
of good schools i ended up going to
marine corps sniper school
marine combat water survival school so
pretty much anything i was doing
anything and everything to prepare for
buds uh to prepare to go to be a seal
and uh of course 9 11 happened uh during
that time i had joined in 99
and 2001 911 happened and that sort of
solidified
um exactly why i joined
and so i i did a tour
um with the marines
one eight they went into iraq mosul iraq
uh and then came back and i went right
to buds
and uh ended up
graduating in class two five two uh and
then from there earned my trident uh did
a bunch of platoons at team one um
became an instructor
for about a year and a half at buzz and
then went to team seven and did multiple
tunes there until uh my last deployment
in 2017 which was back to missoula
2017. and by the going back when you
said you you your dad was in the army
for 22 years or 24 years when when he
was in you said most of the time in asia
what part of asia was it okinawa was it
korea was it cam casey
so we lived in seoul korea we lived in
uh beijing china uh we did some time in
japan and uh
and that was pretty much it so
and i know
how was china back then when when you
were i mean even as a kid how old were
you when you were in china i was in uh
kindergarten in first grade uh but i
remember it pretty vividly um you know
it was uh it was a lot different back
then than it is now i'm just seeing it
on the tv now like there's
no vehicles uh everybody was riding
bicycles uh
it was interesting you know we had uh
of course you know my dad working there
at the embassy
you know we had um
chinese nannies because my mom taught
english while she was there but they
were all spies uh so we pretty much had
spies
uh that were trying to gather
information on us get out of here
yeah uh so your nanny was a spy how did
you guys figure out that your nanny was
a spy oh she told my parents uh because
she was
she was getting uh a lot of heat from
the government because she there was
nothing to collect
she was watching myself my little
brother so i think they were on top of
her telling her you know like hey we
need some information and then uh
i think my parents threw a party at one
point you know and had a lot of guests
over uh we lived in an apartment and uh
that's you know they said that the
nannies were super excited and thanking
them because then they could actually
you know report something back um so it
was it was pretty interesting you know
obviously i didn't know a lot of that
was going on but now you know hearing
the stories now for my parents
it's uh what was your job what was your
dad's mos
um
he uh mp i don't know he was uh military
police
yeah got it it was an mp interesting mp
in uh in uh
china base uh
that i mean he spoke five different
languages so it was uh he was you know
obviously the uh army used him in the
best ways they could he spoke five
different languages
how how did he speak five languages
he's
he's a
remarkable human being impressive man
that's
and your dad is a caucasian american
yeah irish
speaks five language what were those
five languages
um see the
i think it's two or three dialects of uh
you know chinese so it's like cantonese
uh something i've and i'll mess it up
but also korean uh german german i think
he speaks some french
and and did he go from mp did he move up
higher did he end up doing other other
things as well or was it just 22 years
24 years and he retired
24 i mean he didn't want to retire he uh
you know he ended up
while we were in korea he went to desert
storm uh when that was going on came
back and then i think uh the time of
clinton was president and they were
doing a lot of uh budget cuts in the
military and he was just told like your
time's up uh it was
it was pretty crushing to him because he
loved the army but you know it was what
it was i remember they were doing that
when we're in the army that come up to
you and they say listen here's what
we're doing we're giving a bonus for you
to leave the army and not stay in and
they you know budget cuts when it
happens
some of the guys that are around longer
they're the ones typically that are the
first to go and they go and ask them to
go maybe they'll give a bonus
uh to ask them to leave interesting you
said you said you you did the sniper you
did a bunch of different uh
uh uh courses and schools that you took
when you were training with the marines
yourself what did you ever take anything
with marines that was as tough
uh as buzz was was there anything that
you did with marines recent there's this
one training i took with them it kicked
my ass it was the closest thing to
you know being a navy seal oh yeah for
sure um you know
the
you know marine corps sniper school was
uh
definitely one of the toughest courses
i've ever been to uh
it's uh you know the attrition rate's
just about the same uh you know the
marines hi they hold that school in a
very high regard so they make sure that
people who pass it have earned it uh
you know and it was i had no you know
i didn't grow up with guns i didn't grow
up shooting uh so ever i was learning
everything on the fly um you know as far
as becoming an infantryman or
just being a comfortable wrong gun so it
was pretty challenging uh but you know i
made it through that and then the marine
corps water survival school is
definitely
the toughest water school i've been to
um it's uh no joke about five weeks and
uh when you come out of there you're
you feel like a fish
what's tough about it like if you were
to kind of give us a you know
so
i'll give you like just a normal day you
show up
you do uh you swim
2000 meters
with full camis every 500 meters you
take off a piece of your camis and then
by the end of that 2000 they are tying
all of your clothes together they've
tied all your clothes together at the
bottom of the pool at the deep end and
they you have a certain amount of time
to find your clothes and put them back
on and then you get classes all day but
the classes you're treading water the
whole time while the instructors outside
teaching outside of the pool teaching
the class
um and then at the end of the day you do
they call it uh you know pt but yeah
it's in the pool so it's like an hour
and a half to two hours of just straight
uh exercises in the pool breathing
exercises sprints that's after the 2000
meters with your full gear on and every
500 meters you take a piece off oh yeah
so you're uh you come out of there like
super in shape super comfortable in the
water um you know that had a pretty good
attrition rate as well for people that
were quitting
wow
um okay so then fast forward to now
obviously we know what happened
a year and a half ago i think was it a
year and a half ago two years ago when
president trump
uh helped you uh uh you know get your
rank back you he gave you a phone call i
think he called you and spoke to you
about uh what took place would you mind
sharing with the audience some of the
events that took place uh two years ago
when he got that phone call sure so i
mean i'll try and uh sum it up as best i
can uh you know i like i said my last uh
deployment was to mosul in 2017.
we were directed to uh annihilate isis
out of mosul um it's a great deployment
uh we successful deployment we did clear
missile in time um and uh unfortunately
there was four
three to four guys in my platoon
who we did not get along they were
younger guys it was their first time in
combat um i think they
their eyes were opened especially on
that deployment it was pretty chaotic
but uh i think they realized that
this job wasn't for them uh but instead
of taking ownership of that they
pointed the finger at me and pretty much
were saying i put them in harm's way i
made them
you know go out all the time and do do
their job
and you know their their complaints
were pretty petty uh they went to my
command after the deployment with these
complaints and the command told them
that these were not
real complaints and to move on uh so
they kept escalating their allegations
when they weren't getting the attention
they wanted so they turned in from i was
dangerous to i was a thief
um of course they had nothing to back it
up for being a thief
and i think the command finally told
them like listen either you guys
move on or come you know come back with
something that's
legit and so about six months later they
came back and had said that i had
stabbed an isis prisoner to death
um and they had it on video um
the command bought their lie uh i'm not
sure if the command ever asked to see
the video or not but because the video
never existed
but the command bought off on it
told them to report it to ncis and so
once ncis
took the
allegations and turned it into an
investigation that's where this thing
really went off the rails we
they had a corrupt agent ncis agent
named joe warpinski took the case um
very young
and ambitious but also very incompetent
and uh he pretty much formed a
prosecution before he started
investigating and he pretty much took
whatever little pieces of information he
could to
you know throw it throw at me during the
investigation and then anything that
cleared my name he would he would hide
which you know we would find out during
this process but uh
it was an eye-opener um you know as soon
as i was accused or not even acute like
the rumors were out there that i had
killed an isis prisoner it was i was
guilty until proven innocent i was told
that by my command
um they pretty much shunned me uh they
you know put me in an office and told me
to sit there and well they wait to see
where this thing goes
um while i was you know sitting in that
office for about a month they uh raided
my house ncis came um
they were staking me out for about two
weeks uh they came and raided my house
while my wife and i were not home
pulling my two youngest or my two boys
out at gunpoint in their underwear and
then laid siege to my house that's when
we knew my wife and i knew this thing
was off the rails
but you know we didn't know what to do
at the time
i had
shortly after they had raided my house i
had moved my family to florida
and then i was going to geo batch for my
final year until i retired
um
they waited for me to come back
after moving my family to florida and i
went to
a tbi clinic a traumatic brain injury
clinic to get checked up uh
it's a normal procedure for guys who are
about to retire to get checked up for
all their injuries during their career
and i was about a week into that when
they came and arrested me and threw me
in a military prison with no charges um
no explanation why i was being thrown in
prison they just said they had orders
from uh
admiral greene who is the uh
the admiral in charge of uh war com at
the time and then also signed off by uh
commander rosen bloom who was the uh
commodore of group one for naval special
warfare
um
any do you know any reason why they
arrested you on 9 11
uh yeah 11 2018 what was the reason
behind that was that like a message i
mean you know you could do 9 12 9 10 9
11 is 9 11.
exactly everything they do and this is
what i learned through this process so
all these actions they took against me
are done on purpose
them raiding my house without myself my
wife there was to enrage me and also to
break up my family and also
to put shame on our family which worked
because our neighbors
were like oh they just don't do that to
people unless you did something
and then
during uh
when i was at the tvi clinic they chose
september 11th for that specific reason
because they know that day means a lot
to us who have been serving the past 20
years and they thought that would make
me snap and i would do something
obviously i'm a lot smarter than that i
just i complied i thought i was like
this is a big mistake um
and i thought that you know in my mind i
was like this is a big mistake you guys
uh this will be fixed but as i came to
find out once you're thrown in uh
military prison
even as a pre-trial prisoner um you are
not getting out at all until your trial
date and
once they throw you in there they just
keep pushing your trial date back and
back and back hopefully you'll take a
plea deal so you know the video that you
say that they sent to ncis and for
audience that doesn't know what ncis is
ncis is uh it's the intelligence
organization right it's it's uh the what
does nci stand for
naval criminal investigative service
yeah naval criminal investigation okay
so once it goes there there was one
video that was circulating what was that
one video with the body that was limping
you apologized for that one video i
don't know what they had john was that
on 60 minutes there was somewhere i saw
a video with you
so embody
there's pictures so what they did when
they raided my house uh they had they
took they took all my phones everything
um
and there was a picture
of me posing with a dead isis fighter uh
along with uh 12 other people in my
platoon um
and also i had sent a text message uh
to a buddy of mine um during that
deployment as a joke um with that
picture saying good story behind this
got him with a honey knife uh that was a
dark humor my but i'll tell you what
that that was the best and pete worst
piece of evidence they had against me um
you know it was the worst because
obviously it makes me look
pretty guilty
but if you you know zoom in on the
picture and look there's no blood on the
knife there's no blood on me there's no
blood anywhere no no uh
nothing that shows this guy's been
stabbed
but they took that text message and that
picture and that's that was their main
piece of evidence they're like we got
them and that's they were going around
telling everybody they had me dead to
rights like he's guilty
he's going away
but they had also since these um younger
guys in my platoon had said there was a
video uh
they were you know they were spreading
that rumor as well saying like because
the judge had put a gag order on all the
evidence so you we weren't allowed to
show the evidence to anybody and neither
was the prosecution or they they weren't
supposed to but as we come came to find
out
they were given whatever evidence they
wanted to the media um to sort of smear
my name
but uh
eventually we got the judge uh to let us
show the video to congress
because
that lie had gone all the way up to the
white house saying there was a video of
me doing
this act and so once we were able to
show the actual video to members of
congress and whoever else it was they
quickly realized that they had been lied
to by the navy
and that's where you know their case
started crumbling is that is that pretty
common though when you you know you're
going against an enemy they're trying to
kill you they maybe have killed couple
your buddies people that you love people
that you spend time with you're
emotionally vested in it they're willing
to take your life
you're protecting your country
there's a certain level of animosity and
hatred that's built for your enemy when
you go up against them
is it common at the end to take pictures
of the enemy you take out is that pretty
common that have maybe not necessarily
publicly let me post it on my instagram
but is it common to to do that to say
hey we took this guy out yeah it's
common uh standard operating procedure
uh for some units to take pictures of
the bodies that they've killed so they
can
you know bring back and uh show proof
like especially if they're a high value
target
and then you know what we were messing
around uh and that's i would say that's
not common i say um
but it does happen uh you know i think
the the environment that we were in um
it's hard to explain to people just how
it was going into that city every day
there was dead bodies piled up all over
the place
uh we were watching women and kids get
mowed down on a weekly basis
just watching isis commit these
atrocities
so we definitely were super desensitized
uh and you know once you you see that on
a regular basis
and you
don't really think twice about messing
around like that
obviously
when deployment's over and you come back
to the states uh and
you know certain people like what
happened get a hold of that picture or
see that
they
they freak out and they're like how can
how can you guys do this or how can you
pose like this and it's like well you
know you go ahead and
put yourself in my shoes for six months
and or however many deployments and i'm
not making excuses for it uh you know
i've said it on other interviews before
uh it was a wrong decision to do but
it was done
you know and i think i paid my dues for
that
yeah and you know uh uh
you've seen maybe the netflix series
narcos about pablo escobar i interviewed
steve murphy and javier pena steve
murphy and javier pena with the two da
agents steve murphy has that legendary
picture that they showed on the cover
their books with
him and a dead pablo escobar on the
rooftop of a uh
building somewhere in medellin
so that's what i mean like is there
there's there's a part of it where
you spend months and months and months
sometimes yours going up against an
enemy where you build up so much
animosity so i guess my question for you
would be the following
what boils your blood like if if if
somebody asks you a question no one
becomes a person at your level
without being
a fighter and having strong emotions
where you're willing to put yourself out
there to essentially bully the bully
you got to have a courage you got to be
brave you got to be a little bit also
you know
uh off you can't be not maybe office not
the word i'm looking for you got to be a
little bit abnormal like even in the
world of business when you think about
some of these guys that build a business
and they ask bill gates so let me ask
you how much vacation did you do says
for 20 years i never took a day off
that's you're a little bit off if you go
20 years without taking a day off that's
not what normal people would say you're
supposed to get eight hours of sleep
you're supposed to do this no if a man
is on a mission they're not wired the
same way to go up against enemies like
isis but to you what what was boiling
your blood and how did you view
isis and what they were trying to take
away from you or what they were trying
to do to you and your
country you know uh
you know what what boils my blood is
that you you said it uh is bullies right
like ever since i was little even coming
up i've always stood up tried to stand
up for people when i got in a lot of
fights when i was growing up
because of bullies or standing up for
other people
um and that's exactly what isis was as
the ultimate bully i mean they were
they were pulling the most atrocious
stuff i'd seen
in my eight combat deployments and i've
seen you know the taliban and al qaeda
do some nasty things but isis seemed on
a whole another level
and you just don't you don't look at
them after seeing what they do to other
humans um
especially you know other iraqis
you don't look at them as human anymore
you're just like you're they're evil and
you need to be taken off this earth
there's no
there's no uh
court or thing that they should go to to
you know decide their fate it's like you
chose your fate by being on this
battlefield and by pulling the
atrocities that you're doing
we're going to kill every one of you
what are some things you saw like what
were some disturbing things you saw
while you were out there
they uh
normally would um you know
be across
the you know the battlefield or you know
in the city i mean if there was an open
uh
lot or field
they would send out women and kids in
droves running towards us and then mow
them down in front of us
trying to pull get us out in the open to
you know help the women and kids and of
course there's nothing you can do at
that point um
uh what else they were doing is they
were putting um silhouettes on top of
buildings that with uh rifles in their
hand
and so and then they would chain women
and kids inside the house at the bottom
so we would confuse the silhouette with
a enemy combatant vomit and then all the
women and kids would be killed and
they'd use that as propaganda against us
um
and uh you know
just some of that some of the other
things i did not i didn't see personally
but the rumors were going around from
the our partner force that they were uh
oiling
kids alive and then making i mean this
is making the mothers drink the broth i
mean
it's very disgusting and disturbing um
and that's that's just but that's the
environment
that we were in
yeah that's intense and you witnessed
the first two not the last one but you
witnessed the first lulu
i mean there was multiple rumors of just
uh the evil stuff they were doing but i
never witnessed those things firsthand
but the first one would them send the
kids and just you know you saw that you
witnessed them shooting them down
regularly uh regular like not regular
basis but we saw it enough times
well let me ask you what does that do to
you psychologically when you see that
what you know so you it's you and your
peers your buddies you're there you see
that what are you guys saying to each
other afterwards what are you thinking
about it afterwards what's what's your
natural reaction to it when you see that
um i think everybody reacts to it
differently i can tell you that each the
same you know
the same reaction was everybody was just
sort of horrified by it but
you know being seals and we have a job
to do we we're very mission focused and
we don't let that uh those kind of
things take us take our eyes off the
mission uh we pretty much
which not the healthiest thing to do but
we'll just take that and stuff it down
be like i don't want to think about it
keep going
and it's not you know it's not until
after deployments usually when
you start talking or telling stories
about the deployment is when you start
dealing with some of those things like
oh yeah we did see that i did you know
and uh it does it has an effect but
during the deployment um i did not let
it bother me
so so it doesn't produce a rage to say
wait till you see what we're going to do
to you as the enemy you know it's kind
of like the movie
uh i interviewed taya what was taya uh
the book uh sniper american sniper with
bradley cooper
chris kyle i interred his wife
and you hear him talk about like
you know here's how many people he
killed and how do you feel about you
doing that he says very easy because i'm
you know killing the enemy and you can
tell
that you know the guy seems like an easy
going guy but you can tell if the enemy
comes to take something away from me
from him you know he's willing to go
against anybody how do you
how do you manage that to not allow the
rage
to
get you to react emotionally how do you
manage the rage
uh we try i mean we train
non-stop uh for
numerous situations like that i think
you know due to our training we're able
to control our emotions uh a lot more in
those type of situations uh obviously
you know those seeing that happen does
uh
spark a reaction and yeah i think you
know we were
we were pretty much dead set on
annihilating every one of them while we
were there um i
you know it's like i said i looked at it
as just taking evil off this earth um
you know the people of iraq don't
deserve to have those people there
holding them hostage for years how do
you train your emotions though i mean
there's a big difference between
you training to shoot something you know
uh because you're a marksman or you you
can train to swim and last a long time
all that stuff but how do you train
emotional when
you see that kind of atrocity right in
front of what is the method of training
to control your emotions i would i would
say uh
i wouldn't say like there's training i
just say you learn to stuff your
emotions you stuff them down and you
keep going uh
you know i don't think that's the the
right answer either because obviously
those will come bubbling back up later
on in life
you're gonna have to deal with them but
during that time that's that's how we do
it we need to get the job done we're all
about getting the job accomplished and
we'll do whatever it takes to do it i
mean you know you know the difference
you know some my dad would say sometimes
it's better to explode it to implode
because if you
constantly keep it inside of you one day
when you do it's it's uh
it's explosive because you you it's rage
building up for years where
you don't know at what levels to to stop
when that happens to you by the way what
is the best way to describe who
ncis would be like meaning you know
we're not in the world this ncis
uh let's just say in the business world
if i'm the business owner small business
owner creating jobs
is ncis the government is ncis the
regulators as ncis
so who is ncis to you
uh ncis so what what they claim and this
is what they told me when they tried to
interrogate me is that they are like the
fbi uh which is not even close um
so
ncis agents all have tried out for the
fbi or other three letter agencies and
have failed out and that's this is their
last attempt that's
who will take them right so they're
they're very uh it's like the barney
five squad um if you will um and like i
said they they're very incompetent at
investigating but they are all very
ambitious because they're trying to make
it to that next level
yeah i mean the barney five squad if
people don't know what the barney five
squad is that we have to put a picture
for people know what that is but uh
so so do they like people like you does
ncis like people like you and if they
don't why not
you know from my experience um being in
no ncis does not like uh they don't like
navy seals they're always looking to
take someone take one down because uh
they look and this is a
sick way
of looking at it but they look at it as
like a big career move to them they can
bag a navy seal make headlines um then
they can move up in their whatever
ladder of their uh career but uh
you know because i've had you know my
first platoon chief in iraq was uh
taken out uh by ncis about midway
through our deployment and uh they
ruined his career over nothing
and then
from then on i've always you know seen
ncis messing messing around with other
guys and so i knew once uh
they came and tried to talk to me i mean
i i knew they weren't on my side even
though they try to give you the whole
rigmarole of like oh we're here to
actually investigate just talk about it
i i knew they had a bias
but you know i was polite to them when
they talked to me and i told them hey
you know no offense but i want my lawyer
present and uh once i told him that they
left the room and locked me in a room
for seven hours while they raided my
house yeah i i guess where i'm trying to
go with this to get perspective for the
audience so there's roughly
2500 active navy seals today okay
in america we have roughly 2 500 3 000
billionaires in america today right
who goes after billionaires typically
you know an aoc or bernie sanders goes
after billionaires you guys are too rich
and elizabeth warren you know and it's a
card i gotta go take this one guy down
because he's too rich right
is it a similar analogy where they kind
of want to have like i took this navy
seal down is it kind of like that
yeah oh for sure uh you know the best
way i can describe it is you know it's
just weaker men trying to take down
stronger men than them uh they're
they're beta males um and they they hate
the fact that uh we
we are what we are and i think they're
they're constantly looking for a reason
to uh try and take us down you talk
about that in your book you talk about
beta males cowards weak entitled
millennials
tell me a little bit more about that
what does a beta male look like what
does an entitled
uh a generation look like to you
you know i i don't think you can uh
say
base it on looks uh i've you know i
actually had this conversation with my
youngest son too long ago and i was like
you know
a beta male is somebody who is
con pretty much plays the victim role
all the time uh it's always a victim and
then they're always trying to take down
better people than them they uh they
don't like who they are um but so
instead of trying to fix themselves
they're just gonna take down people who
they think are
bigger than them or better than them
i think we've got a few of them today
maybe a handful of them in america today
you know they're
trying to count all of them there's a
handful i think we have in america today
and they i can't see them liking
somebody like you
uh uh uh especially in your world
because to be a navy seal you got to put
your butt on the line now you know i've
asked this question before whether it
was with you know any of these military
guys i've interviewed whether it's jaco
or paronto or even mcchrystal
you go through you know with some of
them on the left some of them on the
right you know you ask them these
questions
like uh
when you talk to athletes who they've
been playing for 10 years professional
athletes mba mlb
and they're on the road
you know and they live a certain life
the normal person is not going to
understand what kind of a life they live
right
yeah you talk to hollywood stars they're
a-listers a-listers i'm talking about
the wheel
the rocks the van diesel the dicaprio
the downey jr those guys right you and i
don't know what it is to be those guys
because we don't know what it is to go
to walmart the next thing you know you
can't go to walmart right to just pick
up some milk at 10 o'clock at night
because you're swamped with 50 people
taking pictures from you so we don't
know what it's like but they know
you know if you're a rock star you know
that one movie with mark wahlberg who
was he was a you know i don't remember
what the movie was it was a great movie
uh and you interview a gene simmons or
you know one of those guys and they tell
you the stories like oh my god really
that kind of stuff took place yeah
is it kind of like that where
you talk to a regular human being and
you're kind of like dude you have no
clue what kind of a life we freaking
live when we're out there like i don't
even want to explain to you what kind of
life we live because you would never
understand
what the hell we go through over there
the only do you ever catch yourself
wanting to only speak to
in depth about the life you live with
people that actually can understand what
you guys went through on a daily basis
uh you know it's yeah like that's
definitely a common uh thing especially
when i was in you just you know you just
happen to hang out with other seals like
you don't really hang out with civilians
even on your off time it's a very
very tight-knit uh
community and then inside that it's you
know you have your little tribes um you
know so you have your close friends but
that's
pretty much who you're around uh that's
it for 20 years uh you know it's i i've
rarely had any civilian friends and then
uh it is difficult um
you know and everybody is very
supportive and unappreciative but it's
it's difficult to
uh try and put into words like hey this
is how we live uh this is this is uh you
know what our schedule's like and you
know
i think that the big eye opener is you
know if you talk to a spouse that's
married to a navy seal and what the
family has to go through during that you
know that career um those
they are they're the true warriors uh
you know they they hold down the fort at
home make sure everything's taken care
of they they make sure like we don't
have to worry about as much at home so
we can focus on our job
you know and that takes that takes a
toll on a family but that you know as
long as you have a strong foundation and
a strong wife or a
strong husband or whatever uh you know
that's that's what making how you can
make it through um but it is
you know especially now that i've been
out now uh i think that's why it's it's
very hard for guys to transition out of
that job as well um we are indoctrinated
into a very uh fast-paced lifestyle
where it's just training and constantly
trying to be better than you were
yesterday and then
when you get out
you know that slows down a little bit um
and that's that's hard to deal with
at times
yeah
who is the guy in dallas something balan
is it uh uh uh what is his name john
ballen do you know john ballen
john ballin john ballen mr balan he's
got a youtube channel with a few million
subscribers he's killing it on the
internet right now crushing it and i
think he's a former navy seal or one of
those things i have seen
a couple of his videos yeah he has he
has something in dallas where he has
former navy seals
uh anybody that made it at the highest
level from every one of the branches he
brings them together and it's a
community for job placement to see them
doing what they do next
uh
you know because sometimes to make that
transition i don't know what it's called
i'm trying to remember the name of it i
spoke to the crowd the audience one time
i went to one of those uh before i got
out you remember the name
or something say that again
elite meat yeah that's what it is elite
meat yes elite meat yes
elite meat we had an interesting time
with those guys talking to them because
everybody looks like a stud or a stadet
you're looking at these guys i'm like
okay oh my gosh you look like you'd be a
killer you know an insane c-suite
executive you look like a vp you look
like this and boom dressed sharp you
know to the teen chiseled you know with
the eyes like your eyes would fire in
those eyes and
you know how hard is it to transition
for you from that life
to civilian life i was only in for three
years and it was pretty hard to
transition from that life to civilian
how hard is it for someone like you to
go at your level to go from that life to
the civilian world
um you know it's tough uh i'm not gonna
lie you know i just spent this whole
last year uh i'm still going through
transition they uh
they say for uh every five years that
you're in it's gonna take two years to
transition so i mean i don't know if
that's uh
you know magically correct or not but
you know i can tell you um yeah i've
been going through the past year and uh
you know
i i had a especially unique transition
because of everything i went through in
my past year just my face was you know
all over the place
but
my wife uh you know she pretty much
mandated last year she's like all you're
going to do this year is fix yourself
and get treatments uh for all of your
injuries and just learn how to sort of
slow down
and relax uh you know of course because
once i got out i was you know pretty
much biting the carpet like trying to do
something else um and i could tell you
that's the best thing
i've done uh
you know i
i definitely it we went through some you
know rough patches last year just but uh
that's
that's the name of the game you know you
uh you give your life uh to to an
organization and you give your literally
uh blood sweat and tears and then
pieces of your brain and you know
everything else
yeah you're gonna have some
repercussions uh that you know they say
if you touch war it touches you back
which is completely true and uh you know
that's
that's what i think people need to
realize is like we're you know these
these veterans that are coming out now
that have been in combat for sustained
combat for years they're not broken they
just need some time to readjust all
right and i think you know certain
certain uh
media um
they
they uh try to say you know say that
we're broken or somehow uh
uh say that we're messed up and uh
that's it's not true um there's help out
there um you know i you know i talk to a
therapist once a week um just to
you know and whatever i can do to
help myself because uh what you know
what i tell guys is you know you can't
take care of
anybody else until you can take care of
yourself until you fix yourself you
can't take care of your family until
yourself is fixed and so that's you know
i'm glad that i spent the last year
doing that you know and it's it's going
to be a constant uh
work in progress um you know it's never
going to go away is there the itch to
want to go is that what it is is it like
i miss i got to get back i'm like this
is too slow for me this is that what it
is or is it just recollections of events
that took place
uh is it is it rage is it frustration is
it people don't understand me what is it
uh for well i think it's different for
each individual um you know i don't
think we all have the same um
problems when we get out for me it was
you know my my levels were off as far as
uh
my dopamine um
i was in fight or flight 98 of the day
uh without even knowing it um i
literally thought like this is
how i am uh
until you know i went and got a bunch of
my levels checked and they're like yeah
you're
all this all your levels are messed up
because of the past 20 years you've been
constantly fighting and being in this
like fight-or-flight stage and that's
how your body
thinks it's you know it works now i
think that's how it's supposed to be so
i would
i would find myself you know just i
could be doing something normal like
watching tv and then um all of a sudden
i
have the urge to go like out and do
something you know
to go do something
that's not like i'm in a rage or
anything like that it's more just
internal
and then i think what comes with that
when you realize you can't go do
something you know guys get depressed
what is my purpose now
why
what am i here for
so
there's a lot of those factors involved
as well um
and i think that that's a pretty common
theme with a lot of guys it's just
the purpose eddie is
your father do is he still around is
your father still around
and do you and him speak like was he one
of the better people to speak to that
understood like that that for you was
like a source of
release when you spoke to him
uh yeah you know i always have great
conversations with my dad i think it's a
little uh
he understands some uh you know
he you know he went to desert storm
um he understands the military and how
it works i i think he has
he has any admits you know he doesn't
know what it's like to uh
be in sustained combat for that long um
but he's definitely he's always a good
shoulder to lean on and just talk to you
that's cool yeah i mean i i can i can
only imagine you know when you can have
uh talk to somebody because you know
even
some of the uh deeper insecurities you
even don't want to talk to some
therapist sometimes it's hard to even
bring it out you know you can't even
talk to your spouse sometimes sometimes
it's easier to talk to
a father or a mother that you know you
know it's going to stay there when
you're talking and that's great to hear
so uh you know if you don't mind taking
a minute the book i mean obviously you
know we've talked a lot about a lot of
different things here but your book the
man in the arena from fighting isis to
fighting for my freedom uh what what can
the viewer right now expect from buying
your book what would they read about in
the book
uh so you're pretty much going to read i
mean i
go through uh some of my childhood uh
get some context to sort of who i am how
my wife and i met
but it's mainly focused around um that
that deployment uh
in 2017 and then the two years that
followed afterwards and all you know me
being locked up for nine months and then
going to the trial
uh but the reader will be able to see
just everything that we went through
because uh you know what was reported
by the media um which was a lot of
misinformation and just
straight out lies um you know that's
what i think that's what a lot of
americans saw
and then all of a sudden they saw that i
was acquitted and they're like oh okay
well there's a lot that goes into that i
mean um
and uh just from all like the deceit and
corruption uh by the government by the
prosecution um
and so i go through all that i go
through my time in the brig and just
everything that was going on there and
then the really cool part is you know i
have
my wife andrea um tells what she she was
going through she tells you know what it
means to be a spouse uh how it was being
a spouse in the seal teams and then what
she went through during that whole
ordeal and i mean
what her my my brother has chapters in
it um so what her my brother did was
beyond extraordinary baby as soon as
they had locked me up my wife
pretty much stood up and said you're not
doing this to him um and she started a
uh organ uh
a grassroots uh instagram
campaign putting the truth out there and
what was really going on and she gained
a pretty massive following which then uh
got her on fox news
and
then my brother at the same time was
knocking down doors at congress trying
to get a congressman to pay attention to
what was going on because pretty much my
rights were being violated left and
right i was not being given due process
um and it wasn't until you know they
both got 50 republicans to sign a
petition
to let me out of prison so i could
probably defend myself and that's when
the president stepped in and said okay
let him out of prison so he can properly
defend himself uh you know he wasn't
saying i was guilty or not guilty he was
just like
due to his service to his country you
know give this guy due process um and
but you know
that's where um
because of the uh state our country was
in at the time and you had
half the country who hated the president
um
then half the country all of a sudden
hated me because they're like oh this
guy's backing eddie gallagher and so he
must be evil too it was just it was very
eye-opening uh
the whole fake news thing we we drank
through a fire hose from that learned
exactly how all that works um
and uh you know we we go through
everything that we went through and then
the really cool uh part of the book is
you know as i was writing it and going
through everything that happened i you
know my wife and i were talking i was
like no one's gonna believe this like
no one's gonna believe that this could
actually happen and so i
decided to put in qr codes in the book
so as you're reading along
um you can go ahead and click on the qr
code i love that
well yeah you can watch all the ncis
interviews listen to the whole trial
audio look at all the evidence they had
against me
look at all the text messages from the
four guys that conspired against me
which it shows right there they were
conspiring but i wanted to be completely
just transparent be like here is
everything and you can make up your own
mind at the end
anything you do differently looking back
uh looking back i mean
you know
i i probably i mean taking the picture i
wouldn't take the picture i guess uh but
you know that
compared to what they were going after
me for that was such a minor charge um
and you know my leadership style uh
you know now looking back um i you know
i could have been a little more a little
bit more sympathetic towards some of the
guys
maybe listen to them a little bit more i
was very um target fixated as a leader i
i was like just like this job needs to
get done um and i wasn't thinking about
anything else
so i think you know i could have
improved on that um you know and as a
leader
that's what you do is you you get done
and you self-evaluate and you try to
improve you know nobody gets it perfect
um
but uh you know other than that i would
not have changed uh my tactics the the
aggressive way we cleared muzzle i would
have been way more aggressive
it's
just
if i could have you know
and um
yeah that's it i mean there's nothing
much more i would have changed
eddie what do you think about what's
going on with uh what uh you know
general milly said i don't know it was a
month ago or something he got up and
he explained crt and the direction
military is going i had the
uh the former space force commander on
and he was fired from his position
because of the
certain things he wrote in his book you
know with uh
when i was in 97 i i didn't you know you
and i are one year apart i think you're
79 baby i'm a 78 baby i think you're uh
are you a may 29 when are you may uh
may 29th
may 29th yeah my uh my daughter is may
27th so may 29th so gemini by the way
we're part of a very
interesting camp tupac big e jfk
maryland monroe you know uh elvis
presley brad pitt angelina jolie like
you got a very interesting camp you're a
part of you know
say that again
you know you're gemini's yeah i know i
have to i mean gemini's are very
interesting very creative how they are
but
um
you know what do you think about what
direction military's going right now
what general milly's been talking about
dude
honestly uh
i saw what general milley said and you
know he doesn't believe what he's saying
you know these these leaders and this is
i think people have to understand this
you know these officers
once they hit a certain rank in the
military uh
don't quote me on this but i think it's
like oh 405.
they have to get uh congress to sign off
on their promotion right
so what what happens then they it
becomes political so these these
congressmen or women are like okay well
if you you know bald the knee and like
push our agenda we'll sign off on you
getting promoted and so when they reach
these high levels where milly's at you
know he's still doing the same thing
he's conforming
to whatever
the
current administration wants and
it's not about what's best for the
military it's about what's best for
general milley um and that's that's the
problem i'm seeing right now in the
military is that you have these officers
who are being negligent in their duties
which is to take care of the military
take care of the enlisted below them but
instead they're trying to they're taking
care of themselves first
wow so after a certain level all 405
they need congress's signature so if you
don't say the right thing you're not
going to get the promotion anyways
yeah that's and that's why we call
officers at that level of politicians in
uniform
wow so let me ask you who did you guys
respect like amongst the navy seals who
at that general is there anybody they
would say that was a bad mo you know
that was a bad move for anybody that you
guys looked at
at that level that the
folks like you respected a lot
yeah you know admiral mcguire he was i
mean that guy was amazing he was just
recently on joko's podcast just a very
level-headed uh
take care of the boys type of mentality
no matter what rank he had he you know
he was always making sure the guys were
taken care of uh their needs were taken
care of which is what a leader is
supposed to do um
you know and then you you have uh
you know i i know you know i didn't work
with jocko but uh i had
you know friends that did and jaco put
us through training i respected him as
an officer when i was going through you
know and i'll tell you what the best
officers that i've ever worked for are
mustangs they're prior enlisted and then
they decide to become an officer
that way they know both parts uh and
they're the most level headed ones
you know and there's there's definitely
a lot of good good officers out there
unfortunately in the military it's you
know if one officer above you tells you
to conform and obey well in the military
we're told to follow orders and that's
exactly what's going to happen and
that's just going to trickle down to
everybody else that's a scary sight
buddy
it is
a scary sight
it's scary it's scary what's going on
right now um especially with the uh the
scraping that's of the military and i
don't know if a lot of people know that
this is going on but
pretty much ncis
uh cid which is the investig
investigatory body for the army and then
osi is the investigatory body for the
air force they're going through uh
mainly special operators
through all of their social media they
have access to it
and if you have
anything that's uh what they consider
extremist which i consider pro-american
so if you are a trump supporter if you
have
pro-american slogans like don't tread on
me stuff like that if you support the
police they are labeling you as an
extremist and they're putting you into a
group right now so that's happening
right now and then what i see happening
is they is just known is this known
everybody knows that this is happening
scraping
no i mean it's being talked about more
recently now i think the news finally
picked it up i i found out about this a
couple months ago from a buddy who
actually saw it happening uh
and so what they'll do what i think
they'll do is once they label you an
extremist it's against the uniform code
of military justice to be part of an
extremist group or a gang or anything so
they will just
you know legally kick you out of the
military
i mean long term this is just going to
lower the standards and raise more
pansies than
raise tough leaders that you need to
protect your country i mean it's just
not a
proven formula sometimes you wonder what
their motive is what the outcome of his
doing this i think that's the scary part
is you have to ask yourself why are they
doing this why are they taking out the
one percent that actually wants to fight
for this country because i'll tell you
being in the military
you learn really quick that whatever
administration's in charge and whatever
their agenda is it trickles down to you
like you get you see little bits and
pieces of it
but uh
we learned to sort of just
deal with those and work our way around
them so we can continue fighting the
enemy right we don't care
i i wasn't political at all when i was
in the military i was just i'll do what
i'm told i just want to go fight for
this country right
well now they're getting rid of those
people with that mentality they're going
after those people and so it's like well
who's going to be left then who's
fighting for them who is fighting for
them who's fighting for you guys
i don't at this point i don't know i
mean that's why i'm about getting the
word out so people people do understand
what's going on and people will speak up
is it is there a high ranking person
that's pretty vocal to go up against
that uh
uh uh
passivisication of you know whatever to
make everybody softer who's who's
pushing back
you see what happens to high ranking
officials when they do speak out and
push back
you just that you talk to the space
force commander i mean
they are pretty much done away with uh
and that's why and that's the big fear
tactic as well they they
you speak out they'll be like well we'll
get rid of you so everyone keeps their
mouth shut so they can keep their job
you know what i think we need to bring
back
i think we need to bring back what was
his name what was uh al pacino's name in
scent of a woman that lieutenant
remember what i'm talking about
even up there
and he called out the entire school we
almost need somebody like that with
audacity to go out there and just keep
kicking their asses
to uh let the world know what it takes
what it takes to be you uh here's the
other question for you so we talked
about those things so uh a ward comes
out this last week that they're about to
make the vaccine mandatory in the
military what i remember
when i was in the army is you stand in
line at maps not even maps it's when
you're going to boot camp pre-boot camp
that one week where you're getting
everything situated you stand in line
and there's air guns with two you know
10 people lined up and you get 11 shots
or 10 shots in a span of two minutes
that's what happened to me when i went
i'm sure you probably had to do the same
thing as well and we signed off
yeah the sergeant will tell you you
can't say anything you're government
property i'm like okay go ahead you know
so you get the shots what are your
thoughts about what they're doing with
the vaccine to say you can't say
anything you just got to take it
yo i'll tell you what we've we've had a
lot of service members reach out to us
uh especially to our non-profit the
piper foundation with that with that
concern um they don't want to take the
vaccine
they
you know it's not been proven to work uh
the science isn't behind it but they are
being told that if they don't take it
then they will be either njp or kicked
out of the military um
i i definitely i don't think it's right
um you know i took
when i was very young in the military i
did the anthrax uh vaccine two and a
half times so i that was about uh
18 shots um you know and i was told at
the time that if i resist you know
resisted taking it i get njp um they
drive fear into you uh but no i think
people need to fight back on this
especially
you know seeing that the vaccine doesn't
work
not all the time so um
you know i think it's just part of the
agenda that's being pushed down they i
think if they
may mandate the military to take it and
they think that civilians will be like
okay well then i guess i'll we'll take
it too but the difference is the
difference argument would be they could
say your government property aren't you
like you know the the the eight years or
four years whatever it is you're
officially government property we're
paying your bills so you got to take it
because we're taking care of you
yeah well they'll say that but that's
you can fight back on that you're not
you're not a like complete government
property you still have rights you're
still an american so you and i could
have said no to the anthrax shot that we
took because i mean i took it as well it
was the same time when we took it and
everybody at unit that fort campbell was
like oh my gosh guys you know we're
hearing hearing there may be some
long-term side effects and then you know
guys will joke around about some things
are going to fall off but you know i
just remember those types of
conversations we'd have but
uh
can you really push back against the
shots you got to take
yeah i know plenty of people that are
still serving uh that never took the
anthrax that refused it um and you know
they were threatened but then at the end
of the day they they still kept their
jobs and
they're fine well that's good to know
that's good to know listen as long as
there's the option to do so you know
they're
for for most of us private's like hey
private you you know you got to go get
it done you got no rank you can't say
anything you just kind of have to you
know shut your mouth and kind of move on
if you ever did it with a private you'd
probably get a lot of pushback but i
wonder what it is to be in a military
today i don't know what it is to be in
the military i don't know what bootcamp
is today i don't know what ait would be
like today i have no idea what it would
be like
to be in the military today like even
the party and like
how careful do you have to be nowadays
you know it's like hey do you not even
party at all in the unit do you make
sure you're doing it off site but what
if you go offside it's easy to target
military because they'll say he did this
to me is it
is it probably i don't know is it a very
walking on egg shows type of you know
conditions to be in the military today
oh for sure yeah um you know i i saw
that the last like
four or five years i was in the complete
shift as well i can only speak to the
seal teams
but yeah there was a shift
and there was a lot of leadership
walking on eggshells
especially after my case
because i think what they saw is all it
takes is one or two people to throw an
accusation out there and you are done
you're guilty um and your whole life is
just flipped around
um but and i think you know what
what needs to be brought back is loyalty
to one another you know what right now
what the military is putting out is you
need to be loyal to the institution you
need to be loyal
to you know enable special warfare if
you're in the seal team the institution
but
in reality you need to be loyal to the
guy to the right and left to you you
know and realize that people do make
mistakes
but they should not be crushed for
making mistakes you should be out there
looking out for them and that doesn't
mean if they make a mistake you should
turn them in or tell on them that's your
brother in arms you you have his back uh
and that's you know that's the way i was
raised in the seal teams um and i just
saw that shift happen about four or five
years ago we're living in the snitching
model though snitching era this is uh
you know california they had the whole
thing where they're given 200 if you can
snitch on people that are
outside uh during the shutdown they were
given bonuses
to people who can snitch on somebody
being outside right now
there's incentive you know you get
incentivized to snitch on people it's a
it's a very uh i lived in iran when that
was normal i lived there 10 years when i
was normal to snitch on your neighbor
snitch on everybody
but uh when that happens and trust goes
down morale goes down division goes up
uh history tells us what comes next
isn't pretty
no
that's uh
you know that's a scary thought you know
especially after being
spending time in a lot of those places
iraq afghanistan um just you know seeing
how
it's it's like that over there you know
that's a lot of the times how we find
targets is people come up and snitch on
their neighbor like oh this guy's
working for
the taliban when in reality that guy
just stole one of his goats five years
ago and now he just wants to get back at
him um but that's that's sort of how it
it'll turn into um people will be
snitching on each other for any any
reason just to get back at them for a
personal agenda um
you know and i think that at some at
some point
i don't know when it happened but it's
like weakness became a virtue uh it was
like oh if you show that you're weak
it's it's strength uh
and that is not
uh how we are supposed to be in the
military you know we are supposed to or
america in general is supposed to emote
strength at all times
and i think that's a big problem as well
well i mean if there's ever been a time
when we need leaders to bully the
bullies
today's the time uh we need strong men
and women to stand up
uh and be willing to
uh take the heat that comes with it i
don't think it's gonna be an easy next
two decades i think there's going to be
a lot of a lot more of this that's going
to be going on but
one thing history tells us is when you
try to overly control people
uh
people who value freedom a lot they tend
to stand up and not in the nicest way
they stand up in ways that
you know uh you just got a brace for
impact when that happens you can't go
like this bullying people for too long
it just
again history tells us you cannot bully
people for too long without them
standing up for themselves
the bowel is going to break sooner or
later yeah i don't think this is going
gonna work i don't think this model
works anyways uh chief eddie gallagher
thank you for being on appreciate you
for your service folks if you're
watching this eddie we're gonna put the
link to your book below as well the man
in the arena from fighting isis to
fighting for my freedom i just checked
it out it's only been out for about five
weeks it's got nearly 700 reviews on
amazon if you haven't read it yet click
on the link below to order his book with
that being said thank you so much for
being a guest on valuetainment
man thank you appreciate you very
interesting stories about what he had to
go through right i mean you gotta think
about how he views as a navy seal you
know what things he experienced the life
how do you go from that to live in a
normal life if you enjoyed this
interview put a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel i got two other
interviews that i think you'll like as
well one of them is with oliver north if
you've never seen that it's a
similar story and he took a complete
different angle if you've never seen
that click over here and the other one
is with a former sniper what i believe
33 different kills that he had
uh nicholas irving fascinating story if
you've never seen that one click over
here thanks for watching everybody take
care bye
[Music]